monday edition of
p-f-t-o-t where we talk about things
that we either didn't get to or things
we would like to continue to discuss and
one big topic and we started the show
with this chris and there apparently has
been some news since then the jaguars
trying to trade leonard fournette the
fourth overall pick in the 2017 draft
taking four spots before christian
mccaffrey six spots before patrick
mahomes
seven spots before deshawn watson it
shouldn't be only the bears who take the
heat for passing on all three of those
guys the jaguars uh even though they got
1600 plus yards from scrimmage out of
fournette last year looking to trade him
ian rappaport of the nfl says the
jaguars are having a hard time finding a
trade partner which is kind of
surprising chris 4.1 million with the
ability to pick up the option for next
year at 8.48 million for a guy that had
over 1100 yards rushing and over 500
yards receiving with an offense that
wasn't exactly a high-end attack what
gives
yeah well he's super talented i mean he
really is but you know i think there's a
few things here mike that are at play
you know one
yes he doesn't have the greatest you
know uh off-field history and i don't
mean that by he's gotten in trouble with
the law but he's been a little bit of
the pain in the butt for the
jacksonville jaguars uh organization you
know of course and the number one point
being you know that that brawl that
happened to buffalo where he ran off the
bench and got involved in it when he was
60 or 70 yards away from what was really
going on and there's been a few other
things that have bubbled up here and
there now you know the other thing too
is he's a violent runner mike he is i
mean this guy's been violent since his
days at lsu and you know even at lsu he
had a bad high ankle sprain you know his
saw his sophomore year the year he made
himself eligible for the draft kind of
hurt himself there you know got in the
nfl he's had some you know some dings
here and there as well heard his knee
slash ankle one time early on in his
career so i think between you know some
of the antics and the style of play and
the fact that the draft is deep with
running backs and the concern for the
shelf life of these type of running
backs like leonard fournette i think do
hurt his trade value overall let alone
it sounds like jacksonville's ready to
get him out of there
we identified six teams as potential
suitors for leonard fournette the chiefs
the steelers the rams the eagles the
bills and the colts we put that list on
twitter and we asked for input and our
friends at roster watch have added four
more teams and i'm gonna go through them
with you one at a time and get your
thoughts cold i don't know if you've
seen this so you're going in fresh
buckingham with hashtag tommy at
quarterback they already have ronald
jones would it make sense for them to
bring in leonard fournette at 4.1
million given what he was able to do
last year in jacksonville yes it would
make sense i mean yes he's better he's
better than ronald jones he gives them a
power between the tackles element to
their offense fournette can catch the
ball out of the backfield too
and fournette is rare in the fact that
mike he can run over four people to get
a five yard gain but he can also outrun
the whole defense and run for an 80 yard
touchdown that's where he's special to
me and yeah that would make sense in
tampa
and to the extent that he needs some
veteran leadership to keep him pointed
in the right direction and get him to
not be a pain in the butt as he is in
jacksonville from time to time if not
more often you got tom brady right
tom brady can't get leonard fournette on
the straight and narrow when it comes to
being a pain in the butt for football
reasons then i don't know who can all
right how about the seattle seahawks
what do you think of them as a
destination for fournette they've got
plenty of running backs would fournette
be better than what they have
yeah well i you know
right now he's better i mean you got to
be a little worried if you're seattle
right with your running back room i mean
chris carson coming off injury rashad
penny coming off injury you know that
would bother me for a team that values
the power running game for a team that
we've seen through the russell wilson
era is pretty patient with staying with
the run and they finally got a decent
offensive line up there to really
capitalize on the run he would certainly
fit their style you know uh brian
shotneimer who i think is a very good
run game designer and play caller he
likes to pull guards smash mouth man on
man type football running plays and
leonard fournette fits that really well
whether he's following or a fullback or
a guard through the hole he's very good
at understanding how to set up blocks
and then make moves off of it so that
makes sense mike when you think about
what happened last year rashad penny
with the torn acl chris carson with the
hip injury cj process always injured in
some way all due respect
uh they had to bring marshawn lynch out
of retirement for crying out loud that's
how bad it got for the seahawks heading
into the postseason so i think fernette
would be very intriguing there and that
rah-rah mentality of pete carroll maybe
brings out the best in leonard fournette
and playing with a guy like russell
wilson possibly will do the same thing
detroit lions as a destination for
leonard fournette what do you think
about that
no i just don't look at that first off
carry on johnson is a special running
back you know and i know i heard you say
that before we came on air like oh man
they got carry on johnson and yeah
that's right i mean he's a first-round
type of talent who was taken in the
second round i believe if i remember
correctly outside out of auburn was
banged up a little bit last year but you
know i do look at detroit as no that's
not the greatest fit and i just don't
think right now if i'm detroit there's
too many holes on my roster right now
for me to want to trade away for a you
know a running back who's going into
year five of his career
yeah i agree with you there and i
they're really really desperately trying
to impose that patriot way
in detroit and le there's nothing about
leonard fournette's career so far that
cries out that he would be
uh happily compliant with the patriot
way all right one more that was
suggested the uh where is it where is it
i had it i had it i should remember
where all the dolphins the miami
dolphins what do you think of them
i i get that i do
and especially with all the assets they
have in the draft i mean leonard
bournette you know again for a team like
the dolphins would make a lot of sense
to me
it would first off you know like i said
in the show earlier today this is a
super talented running back you know we
just talked about he has power to make
people miss in space can outrun you for
80 yard touchdowns and you know i think
you know just again to to miami they
don't have that type of money back of
course you know they really don't have
that offensive guy in general other than
devonta parker that a defense can focus
on and of course he is a little bit of
an injury history that would make sense
to me you know and again leonard
fournette i just want to remind people
he's played in jacksonville there hasn't
been a passing game you know you
mentioned like all the players they
passed up in the draft to take leonard
fournette they didn't they could have
got watson or mahomes or a few other
guys yeah because they were all in on
blake bortles at the time and blake
bortles couldn't throw the football so
everybody was just worried about
stopping leonard fournette and running
that's all it came down to and man
that's tough sledding so
that's the one thing i want people at
least in my eyes to know he's more
talented than the stats are gonna show
he's had nothing as far as offensive
help around him to open the field up a
little bit what are you smirking about
over there
i'm just thinking about one of the first
things i ever heard you say about blake
bortles and it is one of the most
cutting statements i've ever heard about
a football player he was not put on
earth to throw a football
i just every once in a while i think of
that and smile although it's an awful
thought it's not inaccurate and i don't
think he currently has a team does he
no mike he doesn't and i'll be shocked
to see if he does have a team when it's
all said and done
so yes i and again you know i never
happy about saying those type of things
it's purely football when we're talking
that and this is a guy who was born as a
lefty and throws righty you know i don't
know what else anybody i've ever talked
to says he does everything lefty and he
tries to throw righty and it's just yes
it's not natural as we've seen and as
you know it's starting to kind of show
itself to the rest of the nfl i mean the
rams would have signed them back already
if they felt like oh blake bortles is he
can throw the ball over the field he's a
good backup for jared goff that would
have already happened but you know
that's not the case so we'll we'll see
where that goes but i think that has to
be used a little bit in leonard
fournette's defense at least of maybe
why he hasn't lived up to being the
fourth pick in the draft type billy
i'm scrolling through some of the other
comments plenty of
people pointing out how dumb we are for
suggesting the teams we did i see
somebody suggesting the packers i mean
all due respect aaron jones i'll take
aaron jones over leonard fournette any
day of the week what about you
no i will not i would take leonard four
now i like aaron jones yes i know i like
aaron jones a lot but i would take
leonard fournette leonard fournette's
gonna bring a little different element
you know to the running game i don't
think that's crazy if green bay could
get him for a decent price that would
make sense too you know what what teams
did people think we're stupid about like
that
i swear i want to like i would be more
interested all of them well damn they're
then they're stupid too because i
thought we picked some pretty good ones
the chiefs and the bills were the two
and the cults that were getting the most
uh the most pushback because the colts
have marlon mack the bills have devin
singletary and the chiefs have damien
williams who had 498 rushing yards last
year and he had 90 on one play chris you
take away the 90-yard touchdown run
against minnesota he had 408 rushing
yards for the season on a team that
should have plenty of running lanes
given that they're worried about patrick
mahomes
well definitely you know and people got
to get out of this like one running back
thing like get out of it you need more
than one i mean look at the 49ers they
just went to the super bowl we don't
even know who their starter is they have
like four guys that are their starter
how about the new england patriots
who've only been in the super bowl for
the last 20 years you know how many
running backs have they had on a yearly
basis that's three it's four running
backs every game you know the eagles the
year they won the super bowl it was
running back by committee so you can't
just have one and man i didn't know the
world anointed devin singletary and
marlon mack game breaking game changing
type running backs whoa i must have
missed out on that i didn't know they
were all pro last year you know and
again i'm more into what's there to be
had everybody's gonna run for good yards
in indianapolis and buffalo they got
good offensive lines they know how to
run the football it's about okay
everybody can run through a hole that's
10 feet wide what are you doing with it
i'm not going to sit there and go whoa
look at that guy he ran down the
sideline untouched for 30 yards whoa
what a running back i want to know when
he got to the 30-yard mark why did the
one guy on the field tackle him and
that's what i see too much from both of
those running backs i wouldn't see that
with leonard fournette if he was there
that's why i would argue that and that's
why i would argue those people that
colts and colts and bills i think are
good fits for leonard fournette
you mentioned the patriots as a team
that uses multiple different running
backs and i think four million dollars
is too much to invest in leonard
fournette but
and and who knows maybe he just would
not be able to comply with the way bill
belichick does things but the guy is
talented that's the thing that drives me
crazy people are locked into a narrative
that comes from
maybe his latter years in college after
he had that incredible freshman season
or his early years in the nfl when he
was banged up he was great last year
1674 yards from scrimmage on a team that
had a revolving door at quarterback and
was breaking in a rookie most of the
season for crying out loud i i i just i
don't understand why the jaguars are
having trouble trading him i understand
why they're trying to trade him they're
trying to change the culture i think
they're changing the offense but uh the
idea that they're not finding any takers
for 4.1 million for a guy who did what
fournette did last year when melvin
gordon getting 8 million and kenyon
drake's getting 8.48 million 4.1 million
is a bargain chris
well yeah it's a bargain but people
don't want to make trades right now you
know that that's the the big thing i
think more than anything and with the
you know the draft looming four days
away mike i think most teams are going
into it that have running back needs
that are just gonna right now go let's
see how the draft plays out
and then a week after the draft if we
didn't come away with a running back or
at least one that we feel like can help
our team be productive this year then
they maybe call the jacksonville jaguars
and get involved in this conversation so
i think that's really when
we're gonna hear more chatter about the
leonard fournette talk it's gonna be
that week to ten days after the draft
where teams reevaluate where they are
offensively
one last point to keep in mind here if
the jaguars ultimately cannot trade
leonard fournette i'm told that
the fight over whether or not his
guaranteed money has voided based upon
the suspension that occurred back in
2018 that has been tabled that is back
bernard and in theory the jaguars could
cut him
and try to shut off that valve and not
owe him anything
and that would be a risky play for them
chris because the jaguars are one of the
teams that will take the offset language
out of
the rookie contract given to a player
taking high in round one so they're
paying him 4.1 million even if he lands
somewhere else if they cut him and they
lose that grievance that is aimed at
invalidating the guarantee but that may
be what they have to consider next do we
keep him do we cut him and risk owing
him the 4.1 million anyway what do we do
with leonard fournette if they can't
trade him
they may have to decide to just stick it
out with him for one more year it looks
like they won't be picking up that fifth
year option but they may be keeping him
around if they think there's a realistic
chance that they're gonna have to pay
him that 4.1 million whether he's on the
team or not
yeah no i i know and you know you know
just as we talk about this more i just
sit here and just go man
man has there been some talented players
that have left the jacksonville
organization over the last few years i
mean you know leonard fournette you know
yes on the trade market dante fowler
yannick and gonkways on the trade market
jaylen ramsey gone kaleas campbell gone
i mean wow when you aj bouier gone whoo
man those are some names and uh that's
why i know like you know we talk about i
i counted as rebuild mode i know they're
trying to you know what do you say put
new tires on while the car is running or
whatever it makes sense that's nice to
say
uh and yeah doug marone is going to be
held to a standard this year no matter
who's on the roster and i feel bad for
them that way but this is a team that's
you know building for more from two
years from now and three years from now
than they are for oh we're gonna be a
force in the afc in the afc south this
year i just don't see that happening
hey you know yannick and gawkway is
trying to get traded out of jacksonville
from under the franchise tag and you
know i i think there's concern about how
and gawkway would perform without those
guys who eff up the play in the middle
they've had malik jackson they've had
clayus campbell they've had marcel
darius in the past if you don't have
guys like that who are creating havoc
it's hard to swoop around the outside
and get the sacks and there may be a
sense that he's not in the frank clark
category you know the jaguar is looking
for a one plus for yannick way but
if he's not a stand-alone pass rusher if
he needs those guys in the middle
chewing up blockers and giving him
favorable matchups on the outside then
teams aren't going to value him and
they're not going to give him the
contract he's looking for they may be
stuck with him under the franchise tag
he may be stuck with them under the
franchise tag yeah i i think there's
some truth to that and you know yes i
don't think janik and gawkway is in the
same class as frank clark as an
all-around football player you know
yannick and gawkway there's going to be
a number of teams in football that he's
just not going to fit their fancy
because he's just a true pass rusher on
the weak side you want to put him out
wide let him go like you said around the
edge and get after the quarterback he's
not the greatest against the run you
know really he's not as talented as a
guy like d ford either now d ford's had
some injuries to deal with but i don't
think like his top end talent is as
talented as dave ford either so yeah i
don't think this is like a a slam dunk
oh we're definitely gonna number one
pick for a guy like anik and gawkway i
don't think that's gonna happen no i
don't and like i said i think there's
some schemes that are gonna look at him
and go he doesn't really fit here with
what we do and that's going to cancel a
number of teams out as well
all right we got to run because we got
plenty of other things happening today
chris yeah we got an unbuttoned coming
out with his offensive line rankings and
he's talking to cj henderson i got chase
young in about an hour i got to go get
ready for that joe burrow later in the
day for pftp i'm going to talk to rich
eisen as well he's going to be involved
with the charitable aspect of the nfl
draft on thursday friday and saturdays
to try to try to raise money for covet
19 relief efforts so we got a lot going
on this week thanks for some of your
time there's going to be plenty of
content available throughout the various
nbc sports platforms and we appreciate
some of your time and attention as we
get you ready for the draft chris great
as always we'll see everybody back here
on tuesday
see ya
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports